(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] The music is catchy,
it's upbeat, and it's
urging young Russian men
to join the infamous
Wagner mercenary group.
(narrator speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] There are
also social media posts
and highly produced action movies
portraying fighters as heroes.
Wagner has played a major role
helping Russia's depleted
forces in Ukraine,
but as its own losses mount,
the group needs more mercenaries to fight.
It's spent months recruiting
from Russia's prison system
but stopped the practice in February
without giving a reason.
With one source of recruitment gone,
security analysts say online propaganda
has become more important.
So here's how Wagner uses this
content to glorify the war
and sell the idea of adventure and heroism
to potential recruits.
(gun shooting)
The movie "The Best in Hell"
was released last October.
(dramatic music)
(narrator speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The dramatic
music, special effects
and professional camera work make it look
like a Hollywood action movie
but it's actually a Russian production.
The one and a half hour
film showing a battle
between Russian mercenaries
and an unnamed enemy was produced
by Wagner's founder Yevgeny Prigozhin.
He's a close ally of the Russian
president, Vladimir Putin.
Security experts say this
and other such movies create
a heroic image of the group,
which Prigozhin can use to boost
his position within Russia.
(upbeat music)
Also online are these music clips.
The production is less polished
but the lyrics suggests that
being a mercenary for Wagner
is more exciting than
everyday life in Russia.
(singer singing in foreign language)
- [Narrator] There are
even lyrics on screen
for viewers to sing along with.
(upbeat music)
Another video, uses a female voice
and characters from Japanese
anime to appeal to young men.
The Wall Street Journal wasn't
able to determine the origins
of these clips, but
The Journal established
that they've been posted
on Wagner linked social media accounts
and pro-Kremlin online
communities since September
around the time Wagner
watchers say the group
expanded its recruitment efforts.
(singer singing in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Analysts say these
and other similar videos on social media
make the war look like a video game
and trivialize violence
against Ukrainians.
Some security experts say
Wagner has been desperate
for new recruits.
In January, the US State
Department said the group
had up to 50,000 mercenaries
fighting in Ukraine,
many of them prisoners
but a Russian prisoner
rights organization estimated
that about 40,000 either
deserted or surrendered
or were injured or killed.
Recent Wagner videos give a glimpse
into the company's losses.
Here Yevgeny Prigozhin laid flowers
at a graveyard in Russia's south.
(Yevgeny speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Another video show Prigozhin
in a morgue surrounded by
piles of black body bags.
Prigozhin didn't respond to our request
for comment on Wagner's
recruitment efforts.
The Kremlin also didn't
reply to our request
for comment on how the
company's recruitment efforts
help Russia's military action in Ukraine.
(upbeat music)
It's hard to gauge the
effectiveness of movies
and music clips to promote
Wagner to potential recruits
but analysts say this type
of content normalizes the war
as well as the idea
that fighting for Russia
is just another career path
and it helps Moscow to
continue its recruitment effort
as concern mounts among many Russians
over the possibility of
a second mobilization.
(lively music)
(guns shooting)